[Música]
no vamos a la pausa nos vamos primero
Hasta Buenos Aires que este jueves
inauguró su edición número 47 y que se
alargará hasta el próximo 15 de mayo
esta nueva edición estará dedicada a los
40 años de democracia en el país tras la
caída de la dictadura de Jorge Rafael
vidala Videla una exposición de 40 fotos
marcará este homenaje además se pondrá
el foco sobre el escritor Porteño Jorge
Luis Borges todo ello junto a un amplio
panel de escritores nacionales e
internacionales nuestro corresponsal
natalio cosoy estará cubriendo este
evento y hoy nos adelanta algunos
detalles natalio qué esperan los
organizadores en términos de asistencia
a la feria en esta edición número 47 de
la feria del libro de Buenos Aires hay
más de 2.000 eventos organizados Así que
hay muchísima actividad por supuesto Más
allá de lo que se puede ver en todos
estos stands con libros en todos estos
pasillos del enorme lugar en el que
funciona el libro de Buenos Aires pero
hoy algunos ejes centrales específicos
de esta edición uno tiene que ver con
los 40 años del regreso de la Democracia
Argentina y en ese contexto habrá
eventos para marcar esa conmemoración y
también una muestra fotográfica con
imágenes de todo ese periodo organizada
en conjunto entre la feria del libro y
la asociación de reporteros gráficos de
la República Argentina también se marcan
aquí en la feria del libro los Cien años
de la ópera prima de Jorge Luis Borges
fervor de Buenos Aires y para eso hay
una exhibición y también habrá una serie
de eventos todo eso además de lo
habitual de la feria del libro El
encuentro de escritores argentinos
encuentro escritores latinoamericanos
todo tipo de conferencias y el encuentro
de bookfluencers que ha tenido muchos
éxitos en esta feria del libro de Buenos
Aires siempre que se ha realizado
junto a todo lo ya adelantado que más se
puede destacar de este evento
bueno la anterior feria la de 2022 que
regresó después de la pandemia fue la
más exitosa en términos de público en la
historia de la feria del libro de Buenos
Aires que es una de las más grandes del
mundo concurrieron ese año un millón
trescientas mil personas y los
organizadores tienen la expectativa de
que este año pueda sostenerse en la
medida de lo posible ese nivel de
concurrencia y En definitiva lograr lo
que siempre se busca en esta feria del
libro que se encuentro entre lectores
autores lectores y sobre todo libros que
es lo que menciono especialmente en la
apertura de esta feria del libro este
jueves el escritor argentino Martín